[Musica]
Vi ringrazio per l'invito di questa
opportunità
e
ci sono delle cose che noi la maggior
parte di noi danno per scontato
e però vorrei fare un esperimento vorrei
che tratteneste il respiro per 15
secondi
questo gesto così spontaneo ed respirare
Purtroppo non è per tutti uguale ci sono
pazienti che hanno delle malattie
polmonari per cui la maggior parte della
vita è vissuta in quei 15 secondi in cui
abbiamo avuto la voglia di respirare o
abbiamo avuto la necessità di respirare
il trapianto di polmone cerca di dare
una risposta terapeutica a questi
pazienti pazienti che hanno delle
malattie
polmonari rare la cui origine è spesso
sconosciuta Ma che nel trapianto trovano
una speranza di terapia e di salvezza
la storia che che vi che vi porto parte
nel settembre del 2021 io da pochi mesi
ero stato nominato Responsabile del
trapianto di polmone a Siena e ricevetti
la telefonata di un collega di Firenze
responsabile della
rianimazione delle per le gravi
insufficienze d'organo mi proponeva un
paziente paziente particolare eravamo
all'inizio quasi della quarta Ondata
covid ma lui mi proponeva un paziente
che aveva avuto e si era infettata di
covid nella seconda terza Ondata era un
paziente particolare era un un
sacerdote brasiliano missionario che si
trova vancoungo quando ha contratto il
virus e che era stato abbia trasportato
in Italia e a Firenze perché la casa
madre della sua congregazione era a
Firenze proprio per essere curato a
causa dell'insufficienza respiratoria
grave a cui era andato incontro
Purtroppo le normali i normali presidi
che servono per far per sostenere la
respirazione in questi casi in questo
paziente non erano più efficaci
l'intubazione orotracheale la
ventilazione meccanica non permettevano
più una situazione compatibile con la
vita per lui
per questo i colleghi di Firenze
iniziarono una rianimazione che noi
chiamiamo avanzata cioè collegarono il
paziente una macchina detta ekmo che è
un'ossigenatore di membrana era
collegato attraverso delle cannule che
prendevano il suo sangue
l'ossigenavano e lo rimettevano nel
corpo proprio perché i suoi polmoni
erano completamente distrutti
durante il periodo covid avevamo visto
dei pazienti che erano stati trattati
alla stessa maniera e che erano diciamo
avevano recuperato una funzione
respiratoria nel suo caso dopo quattro
mesi il polmone era completamente non
funzionante la TAC l'aveva dimostrato
L'unica speranza era un trapianto di
polmone
Quindi io capì che la situazione la vita
di questo paziente era in bilico ogni
momento tra infezione o problemi tecnici
legati alla macchina che poteva per
qualche motivo coagulazione delle
Cannole o altri tipi di malfunzionamento
poter non essere sufficiente per
supportarlo di conseguenza
riunì subito il team trapianto perché
per discutere il caso proprio perché in
team noi avremmo potuto sicuramente
trovare una soluzione o comunque
dovevamo affrontarla come teen Working
le problematiche principali erano tre la
prima che fino a quel momento pazienti
con un supporto extra corporeo più di 4
per più di quattro settimane venivano
escluse dal trapianto perché i risultati
letteratura in passato su questi
pazienti
erano disastrosi una mortalità altissima
e quindi il rischio di sprecare anche la
donazione l'organo che veniva Donato
un altro problema importante era che ci
trovavamo di fronte a una infezione
quasi sconosciuta ancora nel 2021 Non
sapevamo se l'immuno soppressione
necessaria a far sopravvivere l'organo
nuovo nel paziente avrebbe potuto
riattivare questa infezione virale e
quindi vanificare il trapianto
in ultimo per me che sono il
responsabile del centro trapianti
era valutare il rischio per gli
operatori
la manipolazione dei polmoni nel
paziente nei polmoni nativi nel paziente
avrebbe potuto creare dei problemi di
infezione degli operatori o comunque
trasmissione di un virus che magari era
rimasto latente all'interno di questi
polmoni malati
i pochi trapianti fatti nei mesi
precedenti nel mondo avevano dimostrato
che tutto sommato il rischio di
reinfezione era molto basso dopo il
trapianto così come la sicurezza per il
team i trapianti che erano stati fatti
nei pazienti coviti in quel periodo
erano stati erano trapianti molto
precoci quindi questo era il trapianto
in cui venivano proposto il trattamento
dopo un periodo estremamente lungo di
circolazione extracorporea mai tentato
prima
chiaramente L'unica speranza era il
trapianto E noi come centro decidemmo di
offrire il trapianto al paziente che fu
trasportato assieme Chiaramente in modo
da essere subito disponibile nel caso ci
fosse stata una donazione il trasporto
fu fatto attraverso un ex-motim che noi
abbiamo in Regione Toscana e
un'ambulanza speciale costruita apposta
per trasportare questi pazienti
attaccati alla macchina extra corporea
il 19 di novembre del 2021 quindi dopo
circa un mese un mese e mezzo
dall'immissione in lista
fui allertato dal centro nazionale
trapianti
in una regione del nord era successo un
incidente gravissimo dove tre ragazzi
erano morti sul colpo Uno era stato
miracolosamente
trasportato in ospedale e avevano
cercato di salvarlo Ma purtroppo era
andato in morte cerebrale a causa del
trauma cranico
i familiari i genitori avevano
acconsentito la donazione e quindi
polmoni erano stati offerti per il
trapianto il centro trapianti della
Regione dove era successa questa
quest'incidente aveva rifiutato questi
polmoni così come altri centri del nord
che erano prima di noi nella successione
della locazione dell'organo
l'esclusione era stata fatta sulla base
di una di un referto TC del radiologo
che parlava di contusione di questi
polmoni dovuti al trauma
Tuttavia avevo imparato nel negli anni
che alcune di queste lesioni polmonari
descritti chiaramente dal radiologo
perché presenti dopo il trapianto
andavano incontro a un recupero completo
e non erano una controindicazione al
trapianto di per sé Però avevo bisogno
di vedere le immagini da poche settimane
il centro nazionale trapianti aveva
messo in opera un sistema per la
condivisione delle immagini per il
trapianto di polmone e quindi chiesi che
mi venissero inviate
preallertai gli anestesisti il team
prelievo i volontari della Misericordia
che fanno questo servizio di trasporto
del team prelievo nei centri poi di
donazione gli anestesisti della sala
operatoria gli infermieri
il sistema dopo mezz'ora riuscì a
inventarmi le immagini i polmoni non
erano così compromessi e
decisi insieme con altri colleghi di
provare a valutarli il team trapianto
espianto andò in questa città del nord
valutarono i polmoni ci fu l'oca ai
polmoni Quello che chiamiamo noi l'okay
polmone cioè polmoni idonei paziente
trasportato quindi ricevente trasportato
in sala e iniziamo il prelievo dei
polmoni nativi nel frattempo i colleghi
prelevavano i polmoni dal donatore e in
una
concertazione il più possibile precisa
per diminuire i tempi di ischemia
riuscimmo a togliere i polmoni nel
momento in cui gli polmoni nuovi stavano
arrivando in sala operatoria
il trapianto fu abbastanza complesso e
durò molte ore dove equipe di
anestesisti e chirurghi si alternarono
al tavolo proprio perché per dare il
massimo di quella che era la nostra
esperienza e della massimo della
freschezza dei chirurghi per
l'intervento
l'intervento finale 4 di notte del
giorno successivo e il paziente fu
trasportato in rianimazione i polmoni
funzionarono subito molto bene e dopo
due tre giorni il paziente fu deconnesso
dalla circolazione extracorporea e dopo
una settimana riuscì a respirare
spontaneamente
trasferito in corsia
cominciammo a comunicare con lui che
aveva vissuto questa esperienza di
malattia prolungata Come in una
sospensione della vita in cui lui stesso
probabilmente solo ora riusciva a
focalizzare quella che erano stati i
pericoli ma anche il dolore anche di
comunque vivere una vita attraverso una
macchina fuori di lui io per scherzare
gli dissi vedi Enrico è come se tu fossi
stato Giona che è stato nella balena
E adesso sei con noi dopo tre settimane
la sorella che è una pittrice viva in
America vi mando questo quadro il quadro
di Giona cioè il fratello e della balena
la sua tenacia e la sua il suo ottimismo
lo portò a recuperare molto velocemente
dopo il trapianto e attraverso una
riabilitazione soprattutto muscolare
riuscì a essere completamente autonomo a
quel punto il nostro compito era finito
lui voleva ritornare in Brasile della
sua famiglia e fu riaffidato al centro
trapianti di polmone di San Paolo del
Brasile
la storia sua è comunque la storia di
tanti pazienti che sono arrivati al
trapianto in condizioni disperate Ma che
poi hanno trovato la rinascita questa
lui è Yuri paziente che ho trapiantato
paziente giovane affetto da fibrosi
cistica che mi mandò questa foto Il
giorno della dimissione penso che questa
foto
esprima tutto quello che è la rinascita
di questi pazienti tutta la seconda
occasione che lei la vita gli ha dato
pensando a tutti gli OSS e gli
infermieri e i perfusionisti gli
anestesisti chirurghi di pneumologi che
lavorano ogni giorno per questi pazienti
mi viene da pensare che questa dedizione
non è solo un lavoro è si fa perché si
deve fare perché qualcosa più forte di
noi e perché appunto strappare una vita
alla morte a un valore assoluto di per
sé
e mi viene da pensare che è importante è
un valore assoluto sia nel cuore della
notte in un Policlinico Universitario
come in mezzo al mare nel golfo nel
Golfo di Sicilia
e come è scritto nel libro del Talmud
che salva una vita salva il mondo Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]